hello everyone if you enjoyed my
previous videos featuring chess sorcery
then you're really gonna love this one
when I see this game I imagine a Rashid
nojima Dino watching the game and sing
nice because the game is the game is
well out of this world
it was played in 1968 in a Spanish
championship it was played between
Fernando Segovia and Juan corbello and
mr. Segovia was I believe he was an
international master I found his rating
he was rated around 2,400 but I couldn't
find any photo so the hoodie guy again I
know you guys really hated that the
hoodie guy loses every game but I will
try to find a game where mr. hoodie
beats a very strong player so let's see
the game Fernando is white and the one
has the black pieces we have e4 c5
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture son d4
Knight captures on d4 and 9 to f6 Knight
to c3 a6 and Bishop to c4 we have e 6
and Bishop to b3 Bishop to e7 Bishop to
e3 and the 1 castles Queen - E - we have
Bishop to d7 queenside castle and b5 and
white plays a3 not allowing b4 queen to
see 7 Kings to be 1 getting out of that
C file so it's not directly front in
front of the black queen 9th to c6 and
the white plays g4 preparing to push the
King side pawns and ok here black has to
find some interesting plan in this
position black played rook a to c8 and
it might be tempting to play a move like
b4 but this is well this would favor
white for example a capture some B for
rook F to b8 g 5 and after night the e8
f for rook capture some before in rock H
to F 1 this is this seems like a whites
attack is happening before blacks attack
but if you're if you if you like short
positions you might even enjoy playing
this for black
but after g-41 decided to go for okay to
c8
we have f4 now e5 Knight captures and c6
Bishop captures and c6 and the g5 white
decides to sacrifice one pawn so his
attack would happen just a little bit
sooner
tonight captures on e4 we have Knight
captures on e4 and Bishop captures on e4
with the attack on the rock on h1 and
rook H to g1 now preparing to push even
further he captures on f4 not allowing
any f5 ideas Bishop captures on f4 and
we have Bishop to g6 and it seems like
black stopped all of White's counter
play and the black has a lot of pressure
and the c2 pawn with the Queen and the
rook and with the bishop and g6 but
Fernando doesn't agree with this
he plays h4 we have rook F to e8 and it
seems like one stuck to Fernando from
pushing the pawns further as now one is
threatening all sorts of devious
discoveries after this bishop moves but
again Fernando disagrees he pushes h5
and okay it seems like you do get a free
pawn and well one place Bishop captures
on g5 opening up a discovery on the
Queen but Fernando again disagrees with
this he plays H captures on g6
sacrificing his Queen rook captures on
e2 and we have G captures on f7 with
Czech and King to h8 and well here White
has the option of capturing this bishop
and it seems like it's a free piece
black doesn't really have any threats
here the bishop is guarding c2 but
Fernando has a different idea instead of
capturing the bishop on g5 he plays
Bishop captures on d6 would a tempo on
the Queen and now this Bishop is
guarding f8 the queening square so Queen
- Queen to c6 still keeping the pressure
on c2 and rook captures on g5 only now
grabbing the bishop and well if you
count the pieces here I mean if you give
pieces value and I encountered them the
material is about equal here but why is
Bishop and b3 is complete
protecting blacks King from any threats
on c2 and this pawn on f7 is a monster
so it's really hard to find the gameplan
for black here if you would like you're
welcome to try and find a plan for black
but one actually completely misses the
idea here and he plays rook captures on
c2 and he does this with the idea of
Bishop captures on c2 Queen captures on
c2 with check King 282 now Queen
captures on d1 f8 Queen rook captures
Queen Bishop captures a queen on sorry
rook on f8 now threatening the g7 pawn
and after g6 well black is completely
winning here but unfortunately after
rook captures on c2
one completely missed Fernando's idea
Fernando plays Bishop to e5 now
threatening Bishop captures on g7 with
checkmate
so okay we have a rook to c1 check bike
1 still not convinced that this is this
is bad for black but Fernando of course
plays King to a2 and the threat of
Bishop captures on g7 checkmate is still
there so he plays Queen to h8 now
guarding g7 and well what do you do here
it's perfectly fine to capture the rook
and C 1 this would be winning for black
but as Fernando played the game in great
style he will also like to enter the
game in great style and we have rook
captures on g7 again with with amazing
sorcery Queen captures on g7 and now
rook captures on c1 and what's the idea
here well it's it's pretty it's pretty
outstanding if you play rook captures
and c1 you get a pawn to f8 you can
either pick a rock or a queen and this
is checkmate and if you don't grab the
rook if you for example grab the bishop
with the Queen well then you get rook
captures on c8 with Czech King the g7
now f8 with Queen check and what black
is getting checkmated in a couple of
moves so what do you do have to rope the
c1 well one tries rook to f8 &
even more sorcery from Fernando he plays
rook the g1 and this is terrible you
can't capture the rook because well your
queen is spent from the bishop on e5 and
if you capture the bishop with Queen
captures on e5 you get rook to g8 would
check only move his rook captures and
then you just play F captures on g8 you
grab a rock or a queen and it's
checkmate
so after rook to g1 one tried one more
ideas played rook captures on f7 now
protecting his Queen and g7 but well
Fernando just played Bishop captures on
f7 and well here one really had all he
could handle and in this position he
resigned the game you can't capture the
bishop on f7 your queen is pinned you
can't capture the rook again your queen
is pinned and again Bishop captures and
g7 is a threat of checkmate and if you
capture the bishop you get once more
rook to g8 checkmate so in this position
one resigned the game facing a certain
doom and this beautiful masterpiece was
created by Fernando this year Segovia
the Spanish international master I I
think it was an international master
although I'm not sure if any of you know
please do share in the comments so yeah
that's the game this is my third game in
the in the featuring some serious chess
sorcery I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank John Radke Dave Pearce and
Joel Massey for your contribution to my
channel thank Allah guys are really
appreciated as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon